نتفاعل انظار احبهما الجمهور وشغله منصات
التواصل الاجتماعي الفنان السوداني احمد
الدقر وطبيبه الاسنان رؤى كمال
ظهور لهما في المسلسل السوداني سكه الضياع
الذي وصف بانه اختراق للممنوع وتكثير
لتتابعات العمل الدرامي والمسرحي السائده
بالسودان وطبعا استعرض العمل الكثير من
المشاهد التي جمعت حدث ثنائي في قصه رائعه
نالت المتابعه همم انا البنت الحرامي همم
المره هذه انت وصاحبك همم بطريق التليفون
تكررت هذه الثنائيه مره اخرى وتصدرت
اهتماما المشاهد السوداني عبر السلسله
زوجان ولكن التي تحاكي واقع الحياه
الزوجيه التي لا تخلو من المشكله وقد تمت
معالجه القصه في قالب بدعم شيئ حقق
الكثيره من المشاهدات
احمد ما تخليك لا يوجد
لصباح العربيه نحكي قصه نجاح هذا الثنائي
من السودان الريان الظاهر
[موسيقى]
نجرب